a summative mating is the idea that if
you took all men and you rank them on
how attractive they are from the most
attractive to the least attractive when
you raided all women from the most
attractive to the least attractive and
you can think about attractiveness is
built being built from lots of stuff
right it's not just beauty
it could be beauty and intelligence and
so on but if you created this it was
mostly about beauty but you know if you
created that it turns out that the most
attractive would date the most
attractive the middle attractive would
basically date the middle and the low
would they feel oh now there could be
slight deviations but that's what
happened and why because if you're at
the top and you're a guy you can pick
anybody you want so you would pick a
woman who's on the top and if she's at
the top she could pick anybody she wants
you will pick you so now the question is
what happens with people in the middle
you know most of us what what happens to
people in the middle how do we make
sense of where we are in the social
hierarchy
and for me that thought actually became
very kind of crucial and apparent when I
got injured so here's what happened you
you grow up and you have some kind of
space in society and you know basically
where you are and you know who would
date you and who would not date you who
is kind of outside of your league in
general terms and you know where you fit
in the social hierarchy and and I knew
where I wasn't a social hierarchy but
one day I got badly injured and you know
I couldn't think about romantic stuff
for a long time but when I could office
and I start wondering about where do I
fall now in the social hierarchy now
trying to think about do I fall in the
same place I'm kind of the same person
inside but I look much less attractive
right and with the women who would date
me before would keep on dating me now
and I said why would they they have
other options right I'm not the only guy
in the world okay so so it was kind of a
very difficult concept for me to think
about where do I fall like I felt
differently on the social hierarchy I
basically lost my space all of the time
and I was trying to understand how these
social dance happen and how we find our
place and I was really wondering about
where would I find my own mate where
would I fit in this in this scale and
there's a lot of personal complexities
with it but eventually it led me to a
study and the study was really asking
the question of how do we make sense of
what we fit in there in the
and they're basically kind of multiple
explanations right you could say you
never adjust you never if you kind of in
the middle range or the low range and
you only are you have to date somebody
else who's in the middle range you never
make peace with it you wake up every
morning you look at your partner across
your shoulder and you say well that's
the best I could I really wanted more
sadly you know I have to admit my
limitations that's the most I could do
that means you don't adapt it could be
that you adapt it could be that for
example if you're unattractive you start
looking at other features that are
unattractive and see them is attractive
you remember the story from true love
when you have this this wolf Sydney say
grapes over the fence and he tries to
get them and he can't get them and
eventually said ah there was sour anyway
and he goes and eats something else
right so you could imagine that if
you're unattractive yourself you start
valuing if you're a woman you start
valuing short men who are bald with bad
teeth right I mean you just say these
are really wonderful features I like
hairy chest I like bald head I mean you
basically change what you like and that
actually helps you adjust or you can
imagine that you start liking other
things you stop paying attention to
attractiveness and start paying
attention to other things so we try that
in an experiment initially we went to
this website called hot-or-not it's a
wonderful website you see pictures of
people and you decide you rank them on a
scale from zero to ten about how
attractive they are and then you see how
you rated this person how other people
rated them but a nice feature about this
website is that if I rate people the
website knows how I was rated as well
because I have my picture there as well
by the way I'm not rated very high I
think I'm like 6.4 but they're people
who are rating you know how they're
rating and you know how they're rated so
now the question is the people who are
providing the rating they're people who
are really attractive that are providing
rating and people who are really
unattractive providing the rating and
the first thing you can ask is do they
have different ratings are the people
who are inherently unattractive do they
see beauty differently and the answer is
no we all see Beauty in the same way
the people who are 9 rate people the
same way as the people who are 4 in the
hotness rating so so people don't change
their sense of beauty now you could say
so maybe they don't adjust at all maybe
they don't adapt the people who are 4
keep on looking for the people who are
with 9 and or maybe they adapt some
other way so hot or not has another
feature which is the decide called meet
me in which you see pictures of people
and you say do I want to meet them or
not now it's not just rating it's about
also thinking about the probability that
you will be accepted or turn down and
it's not so embarrassing to be turned on
line but it's still a little bit
embarrassing so the question is the
people who are 9 will they approach
different people than the people who are
4 and the answer is absolutely yes the
people who are 4 basically approach
people who are 4 or 5 the people who are
9 approach people who are 9 or 10 people
are a little optimistic they approach a
little too high but they basically know
their range so what happened is people
know the range they know where they are
in the social hierarchy but at the same
time they see Beauty at the same thing
so what happened so how people solve it
do they wake up every morning feeling
bad or do they solve it in some way so
the last step we did a speed-dating
event we got people to do a speed-dating
event and we asked them to rate other
people are lots of attributes not just
attractiveness but all kinds of other
things and what we saw was the people
who were very attractive cared more
about attractiveness this is like one of
the dominating criteria they want to
date somebody who is attractive well the
people who are unattractive basically
say we don't care so much about
attractiveness we want people who are
kind and have a good sense of humor
so what happened is that the way people
adapt the people at the low end of the
scale is by changing their priorities
and office and saying I want people with
different set of attributes I don't care
so much about beauty I want somebody
who's kind good-hearted with a good
sense of humor and that's actually the
story for the petition so that's the
story of how we are coming into a social
hierarchy in a certain place and based
on our circumstances come to understand
differently what we want and don't want
and how we view the world in a way that
is compatible with where we are in the
social hierarchy